♪ ♪
Welcome to "Evaluate,"
the show where I evaluate life
on a scale of six to six stars.
Every evaluation on this show
gets six stars.
On to our first evaluation, A.J.
- Okay, it's from a viewer
named Haddie
from Wilmington, Delaware.
- All righty.
- As a woman,
I've always been curious,
what's it like to be kicked
in the balls?
- [sighs]
You got to be kidding me.
I guess I'm going to need
to find someone
to kick me in the balls.
I'll be perfectly honest
with you, A.J., this--
Aaaah!
Ohh! Oh, [bleep]!
- Oh, no, no, no.
- Oh, God.
- Oh, my God, I'm--I'm so sorry.
I thought you said for me
to do it.
- No, I didn't say that.
Ah!
But it's very helpful,
thank you.
- I'm sorry!
- Oh, my God, wow!
[groans]
[bleep].
It's an agony that starts
in my left testicle and just
ripples out to every corner
of my body.
- Oh, God, that's just--
that's weird that it starts
in your left testicle.
- Oh, no.
Uh, that makes me realize,
you only kicked me in the
left testicle and that [bleep]
old lady wants to know what it's
like to be kicked in both balls!
Plural!
She said, "Kicked in the balls."
- No, please, don't make me
do this again, Forrest.
- A.J., A.J., A.J., please!
Kick me in the right ball!
- Oh, my--
- Otherwise,
I cannot evaluate this.
Let's go, just do it,
just do it!
[both scream]
[wheezing]
[whimpering]
- Did I get it?
- You got it!
- Okay.
- [groans]
[bleep]!
Oh, [bleep]!
[groans]
I give being kicked
in the balls...
six stars.
Oh, [bleep].
Giving something six stars
could be a thrilling experience
if done as an expression
of highest approval.
But when done in a system in
which there is no other choice,
it is remarkably
unremarkable.
Giving something six stars:
one star.